foreign
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of new zealanders
and Australians Gather in memory of
those who have been killed in war
they shall grow not old as we that are
left grow old
age shall not weary them nor do use
condemn at the going down of the Sun and
in the morning we shall remember them
it's a tradition that stretches back 108
years and has become one of the most
important days for both countries
veterans members of the Armed Forces and
the public gather for Dawn services and
marches every year
Anzac Day began as a way to remember the
soldiers killed in the Gallipoli
campaign in the first world war but it
has since grown to include Veterans of
all other conflicts their example should
Inspire us all to try in whatever way we
can to make the world a place in which
no one has to endure the kind of
suffering and torment that saturated
this peaceful Cove in 1915. around 1700
new zealanders and Australians make the
annual pilgrimage to the site in
modern-day turkey
it's now seen as the place that helped
Forge their National identities
Do We Gather at this special place on
the Gallipoli Peninsula to remember all
those who have served and died
here one hundred and height years ago to
acknowledge that those who were once our
adversaries are now our firm friends
it's also an important day to remember
those who died here who were once
enemies but are now friends Alex beard
Al Jazeera
[Music]